let's take some other calls that came
here here we go hey yo my name's Tony
from Wichita Kansas
hey there Tony and Tony is a nickname
also for Anthony or Antonio onward I'm
just listing your podcast right now and
you're talking about the seniors not
being able to have prom and all we've
missed and I'm one of those students I'm
a senior this year cancelled prom I
don't know when I'm going to be able to
walk the stage for graduation my
birthday is on April 17th and I was
going to sign at my school to a college
for wrestling and now I can't have any
of that and it's just man it's hard
doing online school being stuck in the
house all day man I love your show
gang gang brother yeah that's I mean I
yeah I mean I can't imagine we talked a
little bit about it last week I can't
imagine that you know you can't you uh
you know you got to sneak around if you
want to touch a titty or do something
and at your age I look I'm gonna say
this I'm gonna tell you you know at your
age there's probably some women you're
like I don't know if I'm really into
them but if they want to mingle touch
that titty baby okay because later in
life you will want to remember touching
it even if it was mediocre you know I
remember a girl of a-tearin um North
Carolina and that's one of the premier
50 states over there near the East Coast
but kind of in the south kind of people
kind of don't know where it is and it
starts with North even though it's in
the south so it's obviously also lost
but a beautiful place man I got
mountains they got valleys they got all
kind of [ __ ] and the was like I'm not oh
they had a girl there her breasts felt
like a para dama
[ __ ] diapers really you know baby
diapers and when you squeak you ever
seen a baby's diaper when it's full if
you get that hot little that bottom sack
on a baby and they fill that thing up
that thing there's nothing more kind of
fun really than seeing a full diaper
hang off a baby's bottom that's [ __ ] is
funny you know what I'm saying I'm gonna
do that baby is badass that's kind of
the Tony Stewart of babies if you see a
bunch of babies run around and um oval
or a big track or circle or even just
run by you and you see a couple of them
got clean diapers and then that one baby
goes by with that [ __ ] fat back
caboose bruh and that thing is just you
know that that rump has been chunking
bruh or that thing's been front dripping
dog and that diaper is full got dam or
something really you're like oh that's
the Tony Stewart of babies right there
but anyway this lady's breasts were like
that and when you kind of squeeze them
they stayed in the shape you squeeze
them in which is unprecedented really if
you think about that you know really
think about it think about it uh the
titty or something that looks like a
titty okay think about it you got the
thought okay now squeeze it or something
now take your hand off and it stays in
the squeezed shape and you didn't
squeeze hard you squeeze just a decent
amount
you know you squeeze just a Cosi the
normal amount of squeeze a titty would
want and it stays like that praise God
brother but that's how this lady so and
I remember the next day I'd ridden up
there with a band of group a a group of
musicians what were they called this is
when I was living in Charleston South
Carolina over there
this band man they let me get on stage
sometimes and I would wear small shirts
and the shirts didn't fit me that well
because I hit a late growth spurt in my
and but I hadn't really purchased made
any purchases to to you know really
cover myself since the spurt and um
Jesus I'm going off track uh what I'm
telling you is this dude that if you get
a chance bro go and you you just you
you'll you won't regret it usually you
won't regret reach him for that
opportunity bro you won't regret it man
you're not gonna think years later man
good thing I didn't you know put a
couple dollars in the tank and go over
there and touch a little breast touch
that [ __ ] big front knuckle you feel
me
so but anyway man what was your problem
yeah dude I'm sorry you can't go to prom
in it that should has heartbreaking and
and that you know not to imagine being a
senior in high school is you're so
excited you know it's your year man you
get to walk around one of your friends
has a beard all of a sudden you're like
damn Jake he's like yeah I know oh yeah
oh you know things are happening one of
you you know one of your friends gets
knocked up little Deandra you're like
damn Deandra just going on in huh yeah
well guess i'ma keep it oh ha ha
Deandra you know people are making
choices one of your and you don't get
that you don't get to see that every day
you don't get that experience man I mean
I am real sorry man
it's heartbreaking bro it's
heartbreaking
but I think that there's gonna be others
so there's gonna be some other great
experience in your life that's going to
happen because of this there's gonna be
some way that this shakes out that's
gonna be pretty awesome man will it be
as awesome as your senior year of high
school though I do not know bro I don't
want to lie to you man and did not have
prom think about people not having prom
right now
um that's got to be hectic not having
prom there are people there there's
youngsters missing the prom that's why I
said that we should have Amazon prom you
get a box in the mail it's kind of pro
whole prom in and in the box
you know it's $13 is $60 for the upsell
you know you get the you know you get
you get the whole thing in the box you
get a little thing of um lights some
Christmas lights you know you get a
poster it says uh you know a night to
remember or um you know a walk in the
smog or something you get that you know
you get a corset you get up you know you
get a picture of two people eating um
overpriced Italian food you get you get
then you get somebody vomits and for an
extra 13 dollars so that they somebody
vomits in your car an hour later
that's prom that's Amazon prom you know
Tiffani don't have a bra so she got a
borrower Janet's you know what a jan
it's a piece of leg hosiery um you know
uh what is it called um panty one of
them you know uh Nana leg looks like
like a panty no I'm talking about they
got a tire um what is that hosiery they
got a tire hosiery under her breast and
they got a bar at that Salmons on one of
those is in there you know you get a hit
of acid somebody gave you don't even
work that's in there too that's six
dollars do you got it
Amazon prom you get everything you get
that angry parent that shows up when you
making out with you know with a girl
everybody calls [ __ ] big Reno that's
her nickname and you know her mom comes
out yelling and damn Mazda over there
mazda s6 or whatever and she comes down
and tries to fistfight you in the yard
because y'all over there necking you
know you get to pretend like your dates
dress looks good even though she looks
absolutely ridiculous that's prom Ross
Amazon prom you get all that in the box
man you get all that in the box this mic
just broke whatever its life man but
dude I Love You Man and I'm sorry you
know you don't get that and look I mean
you know you you don't get that special
you don't get to go over to somebody's
house and there's a keg and some one of
your friends [ __ ] gets alcohol
poisoning gets to go to the emergency
room you don't get it you know it's
heartbreaking you don't get to take
photos and then you have to take a big
group photo with a group of people you
don't even freaking know and that cost
you an extra six dollars and everybody's
got acne you don't even I mean people
hit and gross spirts even somebody
starts at the prom they're five too when
they get there a five seven when they
leave you don't even [ __ ] know what
happened to Ernest who knows bro who
knows but I Love You Man be safe out
there it evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one